we fully commit to that event the story
is very much about how do heroes move
forward from that kind of a loss its
unique circumstance because I don't know
that there was ever a movie of that
scale in that budget where the lead
character is lost at the end of the film
and that's what we focus on a focus on
surprising ourselves surprising the
audience making really dramatic choices
that we're not sure how we're gonna get
out of as artists and I'm killing half
the characters and then trying to figure
out how you move forward from that that
is compelling place to put yourself
we don't chase bigger what we do chases
great stories how I know whenever you're
working with I am actually thinking
about scale is thinking about top to
bottom as well as side to side
for movies like this with cosmic
settings and larger-than-life characters
there's no better way to shoot it and
there's no better way to display it for
an audience
the epic scale of these movies requires
a canvas like that even if there's a
small chance
we owe this to everyone who's not in
this room to try
whatever it takes
it takes whatever it takes you're
dealing with a lot of really unique
voices you have a lot to say and are
moving in different tones and different
directions making really different
choices from one another and that's
exciting
looks so close to all of them now that's
like family Robert would always host
lunch for everyone every day and that's
probably my fondest memories you know
really was make summer camp for all of
us
I like physical we have to expend a lot
of energy and time making sure we keep
the information about the movie really
controlled and focused and quiet because
you know the pleasure that we get from
experiencing movies for the first time
in the theater and not having anything
tipped it's just like we need it we want
other audiences to have that opportunity
everyone has great TVs and sound systems
at home now and why are they gonna come
out and sit in the theater well you're
gonna give them the grandest experience
that they could possibly have
I think that people who go see it in
IMAX they're gonna be blown away
[Music]
you
[Music]
you